everyone and welcome to today's tutorial
which is about how to contribute to
partner's package
we are happy to welcome our speakers
so before doing that I would kindly
remind you to maybe mute your cell
phones and if you want to spread the
world aboard about this talk then just
share a tweet on Twitter with the
hashtag buycon de or hashtag Pi data
Berlin
and as a next I am very happy to welcome
our speakers Noir Tamir you all know her
from today's morning
talk and her colleague Patrick huffler
who will conduct this session with you
this session is a two-part session 90
minutes
[Music]
each part and we'll have a 10 minutes
break between both parts
yeah so we are happy to have you uh
please give a warm welcome to our
contributors and the stage is yours
hi everyone
um so yeah we uh we're also reusing
these slides that we often use when we
do workshops at Pi ladies event so we
didn't redesign them for you so go to
Pilates events they're awesome
um that's more or less our plan so our
goal is that you get to actually
contribute to pandas today and the QR
code is for the slide so I have more QR
codes rather links but if you just want
to have it use it later or whatever you
could already grab that
if you have a moment I still see a phone
I would recommend grabbing it
self
um
yeah because we do have a bunch of links
to share
it falls
all right
I think we're getting there
so
um a bit about us so you met me in this
morning if you were at the keynote
um but if not I've been contributing I'm
new to pandas I've been contributing uh
only for a year we met here last year
um at this conference I'm self-taught
pythonista and our programmer I'm not
someone who went to a computer science
class if you do want to connect and
reach out to us now or later on we also
included all sorts of
um uh links that you could or or tags
for different places so you could stay
in touch later on if you're interested
and I'm currently teaching data science
actually at Noah Fisher and Patrick
hey I'm Patrick I'm a pandas maintainer
since 2021.
Noah and I are doing this workshops
regularly with Pilates Berlin like every
two months
probably
I am currently working at coiled as a
senior engineer I'm mostly working on
desk and better integrating desk with
pandas in general
um I'm also self-taught I'm currently
doing a master degree in software
engineering and as Noah said if you want
to reach out LinkedIn or GitHub is
totally fine
you graduate you can't say yourself talk
anymore that's true
and yours
also is here with us yeah
um I'm currently mostly in open source
developer so I'm working at part-time at
Photon data where I contribute to
apachero which is now also being used
more and more in in pandas as
Patrick explained them yesterday I'm
also involved in interview pandas the
geospatial
ecosystem in Python and so yeah there
are some links there
so to start with I thought we'd talk
about why are you all here
um so I don't know if you know but other
than
enjoying and uh maybe deciding to try it
out many people decide to contribute to
open source for many different reasons
um some choose to then spend all of
their free time on it for some reason I
don't exactly know why I can't explain
it
um but not everybody and uh also for
yourselves maybe Food For Thought for
later on some people just like the
project think they're cool
and just want to kind of be a part of
the community some people found a bug
and really want to fix it and then
realize how hard it is or easy it is to
fix it some people are studying or
learning something in general and they
just want to be continuously learning
and it's free and open so why not try
and learn in public which I think is
Really Brave and some people are
attracted like I said to the community
or they're just trying they're
interested it's a complex technical
problem to really get into it so there's
many different reasons and not everybody
does it to become a maintainer not
everybody becomes a maintainer and
that's totally fine that said if you're
interested we'd love to hear
um
so yeah I just wanted to create some
space for that to reflect also for you
it's nice you're here trying it out if
you haven't done it before some of you
may be contributed to others uh to other
projects
um so I just wanted to give you a quick
intro to what is uh what in case you
haven't so maybe how many people have
never contributed to open source before
all right
so majority so I thought maybe I'd give
you just a quick intro to what is an
open source project kind of like how
we're organized
um so just so you know that most
projects have established some are work
in progress governance some are just de
facto that means you can read about how
the project is organizing who does what
how often they meet what they do how
they work how they make decisions
um it has maintainers so those are
usually contributors that have been
contributing for a while that know a bit
more that are involved that show that
they're committed and that means I also
usually have more rights from voting to
commit like all sorts of rights in the
project there are also folks who are not
maintainers but maybe very active
supporting and triage teams and
documentation teams and all sorts of
other work so there's all sorts of
working groups and roles where you can
be a member even if you're not yet a
maintainer and some of the maintainers
are also members of of those groups
specifically for pandas if you're
interested
you can check we have about Pages a team
page a roadmap a governance all sorts of
things that kind of explain a bit more
about how the project is organized and
how it works
um there are also a lot of ways to
contribute so when he's like let's
contribute what are we actually doing
here
um you can add tests if you understand
and know a unit tests and feel
comfortable you can open issues and
recognize and especially when we do new
releases that can be very helpful I
think you heard about that yesterday
you can write documentation make sure
that things that are either not explain
or not explained well enough or explain
better for future users you can submit
pull requests to actually address open
issues and try to resolve them you can
review other people's pull requests
that's not something that's res only one
person or or only maintainers can do
triage as well check check if it worked
for you check if you can reproduce a bug
and just help to answer and and
communicate in the project you can
develop educational material
maybe a lot of us are not great you can
contribute a graphic design and
illustrations and help clarify things
visually or make things look better more
appealing more clear and sometimes also
adding translations and things could
also be helpful so all sorts of things
that's a big Community project if you
are contributing whether it's dependence
or to any other project I do recommend
that you look under the hood this is
something that GitHub often helps you
with not all the python and Pi data
projects you would know and love are
mostly Python A lot of times under the
hood they I have C Fortran C plus plus
all sorts of other Technologies and so
if you're a majority of python
programmer it might be easier for you to
join or contribute in the beginning to
projects that are majority python
luckily pandas is one of those
um
so you can see this what there are
sometimes things that you can see we
also for our documentation use
restructured text and sphinx and we use
doc string so if those are things you
any one of these are things you feel
comfortable with you could probably help
and start contributing in the project
um
a little bit about what you actually
need to know in order to submit for
example a documentation PR if that what
is what you would be doing today you do
need to know how to use get in GitHub
you would need to be able to know how to
build a Project's development
environment and documentation or we have
a git pod we can show you how to use
that today because that means you can
use the you don't need to do the
development environment locally but
rather use it in browser you'd still
need to know how to build our
documentation
um but you also need to be interested in
improving the documentation you are
addressing so it's not just like let's
get a contribution in you should you
know care about helping us make the
project better and more useful for
others
um you want to talk about the
contributors guide Maybe
that's Noah said most of Open Source
projects will most likely have a
contributors guide which should explain
roughly what you need to do to get
started the pandas contributor guide
focuses a lot on how to set up the
development environment
like more shorter picture earlier about
how what's in inside of pandas like we
have 90 python but we also have some
siphon which means you have to build C
extensions if you want to get the
development version running
um
what you would recommend for today is
that you use gitpod the setup is like
nearly instant it takes a couple of
minutes to get an account and then you
can get started I mean you don't have to
worry about Hardware requirements or
anything else
if you're not on GitHub yet you should
join and create an account
is anyone not on GitHub yet
okay so we should be good
um
if you want to set up your stuff locally
then you'll need git installed this is
relatively easy just Googling git and
then taking one of the first links
that's not an advertisement
that would be helpful
um
and let's move on to gitpod the cool
thing about gitpot is is that it spawns
basically a Docker container in the
cloud that you can connect to locally
via vs code that's what works most
reliable
and then you can start like changing the
code gitpod is pre-configured from us
it's already it already built the C
extension so you're good to go from the
start and you don't have to worry about
installing a compiler or anything like
this
to have a link
uh to the well the documentation okay
I'll link to the good products in the
documentation
all right so we thought uh some of you
might want to work in pairs
um it can be useful to figure stuff out
together if you're new so how about we
take 10 minutes and you all talk to each
other so I set up some questions that
might be helpful for you to figure out
if you want to work with others or by
yourself but feel free to talk about
whatever you want
um and then we can continue and get into
things because you kind of need to
figure out if you want to work for
yourself or with others and it could be
very beneficial for those who want to go
together
and if not you just met someone at a
conference
because I think it might have finished
in the beginning yeah I'm gonna add it
in a bit I just also want to right away
um let me just make this now private and
then
this will be critical
I think in a bit once they get started
if people have more questions that we
are able to answer at once so I think
you and Natalia can vote
[Music]
foreign
thank you yeah awesome thank you
you should try disconnect and reconnect
thank you
and um
I GitHub today
[Music]
well this is actually the Wi-Fi yeah
I blame both
[Music]
are you inside
um
signal yesterday on this slide today
[Music]
signal but the problem is like yeah
visibility not disturbed because of the
day well I don't know on the train I was
just watching my feet
I don't know I'm not interrogative
[Music]
oh that's great yeah you can do it out
as well
I mean
[Music]
um
let me quickly go
it's over
here oh God this is so hard
[Music]
yeah
that was easy
[Music]
let me try this again
so
should normally
be able to scan it yes how do you do
this do you point your camera at it and
it shows you the like it's right it
doesn't do that for me it's in the
camera up but also networks
you should pair with someone otherwise
there's nothing the rest of the events
we're gonna be doing things yeah I just
tried to see the best practice we're not
going to show anything what they're
going to be doing and we're going to go
and answer questions
can I ask
you can work with someone I think that
would be best
yeah they're taking issues
we have so I have a repo in mind that
has that we linked interest is because
we didn't want people on the main repo
to know but it's a real issues
I'll share the link in a bit but it's
it's on my GitHub not a meal and then
it's like Friday the workshop or
something but I'll show it in a bit
okay shall we keep going
two more minutes it's only seven okay
so
um
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
our program
s
um
[Music]
all right
hey everyone
so
um quick show is there anybody who would
like to work and a parent doesn't have a
pair yet
okay
great then I think we're ready to go
um
so
first before we get going do you have
any like we'll show you now how to we'll
talk about the environment we'll show
you where you can find issues is there
anything you have a question on before
we get there
oh yeah thank you
good pod uh getpad.io I think
um that is this uh screenshot we shared
earlier that allows you to use kind of
vs code or a development environment in
the cloud so you don't have to install
everything on your computer
and so if you don't want to go through
all the installation before you work on
an issue you can launch it wait a couple
minutes till it sets up and then you can
start working on anissue directly
there is a free option and that will
give you 50 hours a month which I think
will be sufficient for today
yeah but I also use the free account for
long like for a long time you could
probably even use it later on for a
while until you decide to actually
install or figure things yourself I
would say anybody who's using a Windows
machine highly recommended that you go
for that option today
it's just harder to set up the
environment yep
we are here and we also have two
volunteers to answer all your questions
today and get you contributing to pandas
awesome
any more
great so
yeah the first thing you'll need to do
is make sure you have a development
environment if you choose to work on
your own machine and set everything up
you need to follow these steps this is
all in our documentation I just want to
briefly go through it together so you're
not surprised by the amount of context
and text you're going to be reading and
there's a lot of different options of
what you could be doing depending on how
you want to set up your machine
specifically and what you have
preferences for but you will definitely
need to be forking the main repository
you need to clone your fork locally or
have a a clone of your fork on your
machine then you want to make sure that
you set Panda steps such pandas their
original repository as the Upstream if
you we also have a Docker that you can
use locally if you want to go through
the docker root or if you're on Linux
then you don't need to make sure you
have a c compiler but if you don't then
you do need to make sure that you have a
c compiler you'll also need to make sure
that you install either Mambo mini coder
and a content to set up our development
environment
then you need to
um just tell us that you're ready that
you have an environment it's all good
you need to be able to build pandas
locally this is great because then if
you're going to make changes no matter
if it's a documentation or anything else
you can rebuild it and see the changes
affect locally before and check if it
works before submitting it
um
and at the end it would be very useful
if you also enable your pre-commit these
are the test the checks that we do on
commits
um once you submit a PR and you can run
them locally before then and find
anything that is already wrong locally
before you open the pr so that's
convenient you can see the bracket over
there shows you that if you go through
the git pod and that's why we said it
will go faster you don't need to do all
of those steps you just need to make
sure you have a gitpod account and go to
that link
um so and the rest you can work and we
also have documentation for how to use
gitpod in our development environment
documentation as well so that would get
you faster to contributing but if you
potentially want to you already know
that you're more likely to be doing more
than just the issue you'll be working on
today then maybe you want to set
yourself up already for future work
locally on your machine and we can help
you with that too
so one of the first questions that comes
up with new contributors it was mine as
well is how do I get started how do I
know what to work on there's usually a
lot of open issues there is some ideas
that you have and it's not necessarily
easy to know how to get started
especially in a large complex project
for that
um we did two things first of all we set
up a repository with where we
pre-selected for you some issues that we
think are nice to get started on
um we also usually on the pandas project
have a label that's called good first
issue so if you're also later on looking
for issues it's pretty useful to look at
that label we didn't label those issues
because if we would people take them
really fast so you if we would have
labeled all of those issues as good for
this issue we wouldn't have any issues
for the workshop today but generally we
do label ongoingly all the time the
issues that we think are relatively
approachable for new contributors
needs tests is also a label that we have
which usually describes what needs a
test very well I recommend that you
scroll all the way down there's usually
a snippet of code that already shows how
the test some some of the functionality
the test should be checking for and if
you're comfortable with unit testing
that might be an easy way for you to get
started I think all my first PR's were
unit tests and in general how do you
then pick from all the available options
to what you should be working on
specifically I would recommend that you
start with what you feel comfortable
doing what's your skill set what's your
interests and then again before you open
maybe issues or want to solve bugs that
you don't know how complex they are and
so on try at the beginning for the first
few issues to work on issues that are
already open that are relevant to the
project you're going to be helping and
helping pandas improve while learning
how to contribute to pandas and how to
kind of navigate the code base and maybe
later on
you could also move to just kind of
identifying things that could be working
or worked on yourself and in general
it's good to start small in the
beginning you just want to learn the
whole workflow of how to work with open
source projects in general and pandas
specifically
so
that's for that this we can do later
when you're ready to open a br
so
one other thing I wanted to show you
is that this thing is a link
and if you'd like you can help us know
how well you're all doing since you're
quite a lot in this room and so you can
add your name and GitHub user to the
list and check off how you're going with
the development environment set up and
we can kind of start seeing if
everybody's stuck at a certain level we
might start explaining or showing things
but otherwise we're also here to just
help you individually resolve issues so
at this point
I would recommend that you launch your
gitbot or start working on your Dev
environment and then select an issue you
want to work on
sorry
that is
setting up your development environment
and
in case you missed it
this is the QR code for the slides yeah
the link is also in the Discord Channel
yes great thank you
excellent
in pandas itself you have a bot if you
comment take in an issue then it will
assign the issue to yourself because
this is not possible if you don't have
any rights in the repository for the
workshop we have today we created a
repository that has like 10 issues that
have each a number of sub issues and if
you want to start working on one then
just write a comment I'm working on this
that's it otherwise it gets confusing
really good question yeah
start contributing to puntas yeah
foreign
one second last but not least you can
also write questions on Discord or slido
and we will also monitor those
things
[Music]
signals
you can run together
[Music]
one question that came up you shouldn't
run all tests otherwise your laptop will
be busy for the next 20 to 30 minutes
and just run a subset of the tests if
you want to check if everything works as
expected
foreign
[Music]
I'm just trying to yeah
great
um
I can
visit
um
also get her voice down this morning so
I almost had a heart attack so it was
like everything is working against me
uh I can't see which one is the sign in
is it this one
or this one
yeah yeah
thank you
now I hope I don't have to attack my
password for another one but we'll see
not yet but
um
is it this
it says
yeah I'm not sure one second
oh hello that's why
[Music]
so this is just what yeah yeah so uh
if anyone's trying to launch a gitbot
and hasn't yet I'm doing it on screen
now
yeah
so I got I went to get getpod.io I
logged in
and then I it launched a new workspace
or went to launch a new workspace then I
picked my Fork of pandas so it has slash
my GitHub username slash pandas
so for people with me great and then you
can decide if you want to have it in
browser or if you have a local vs code
you can also choose to work with your
local vs code installation that can also
work
and then I click new workspace
and it's going to take some time
it's still faster than doing it yourself
on your computer
usually
[Music]
okay yes the internet influence yeah
your mom is
conversations
foreign
um a short note for the people that were
working in gitbots and got an error when
importing pandas that's because
um the python the we put the latest
version of pandas but we didn't properly
rebuild the extensions so the the part
that is compiled and so if you run that
command then normally that should fix
the import error so that's basically
rebuilding the uh yeah all the extension
code in pandas in place
oops
oh
University of
the issue because
of a fixed somewhere
it's
unexpected basically
[Music]
um
it doesn't really show that clearly
a different yeah
foreign
[Music]
um
foreign
that's all right
thank you
very much
[Music]
the situations
organizations
uh
otherwise
come on
thank you
[Music]
um
Administration
um sorry for the the people using gitbot
one more correction uh so this is the
correct command that you need to use to
fix it but otherwise uh what you can
also do or if you didn't yet start
actually making changes you can also
restart gitbots after ensuring that you
sync your fork and then just restart
gitbot then it should also be fixed
sorry for the travels
uh
yeah
so we need to fix our contributing guide
because the comment that we
that doesn't work so the the our
contributing guide says
[Music]
I mean I can fix it now so I can also do
that I don't fully understand why it's
saying that because what we had in the
kitbots was just copied from our
contributing guides
uh I mean but Marco has been updating it
a lot recently and sometimes Marco does
what
way and I'm like I was in a workshop but
it doesn't work for 20 people I'm
changing it
yeah I didn't know if this part is yeah
so the building is thought here so this
first line isn't building in place so
this
so everyone it's
3 35 and it's time for a break so we'll
have a 10 minutes break
um and we'll continue with a session at
quarter four four
quarter to four and I would have a small
announcement to you to make everyone
who'd register for our today governs uh
Gathering event in wavening please
pick up your wrist bands from the
registration desk before it's too
crowded so everyone who will join our
event in the evening the dinner
basically please pick up your wristband
from the registration decks